liebe leute es schneit da möchte man
fast sagen ja ist denn schon weihnachten
ist gott sei dank noch ein bisschen hin
aber hin ist es nicht mehr bis zum
nächsten gast nämlich alpa gun und
schnee erinnert mich ein bisschen an ihn
warum nicht das etwas damit zu tun hätte
obwohl ein bisschen schon nämlich in dem
zdf mehrteiler das verbrechen der spielt
in einer folge die hauptrolle und da
geht es unter anderem um den schnee dem
man sich in die nase pfeift ja und wir
reden natürlich über sein neues album
und vor allem auch über seine neue
youtube schon da ist nämlich auch
unterwegs bei drogen habe ich schon bei
ihm gesehen und natürlich geht es auch
wie immer um eure fragen die am besten
in die jetzt wirds aber langfristig am
besten in die kommentare schreibt als
video antwort hochladen und vorher den
info text liest und euch was einfallen
lassen
dann kann eigentlich nichts mehr schief
gehen und ich würde mal sagen
bis dann bleibt dran